let's quickly have a look at this one a
few errs are kind of like wrestled with
this because it's like wait wait
now that there's other grass in here I'm
getting confused okay let's think about
what we know number one when we look at
this the first thing you might find is
said the cusp and the cusp is going to
be at x equals be careful it's positive
1/3 right so I'm going to mark in 1/3
there ok and then you say oh another
piece useful piece of information might
be the y-intercept now normally if we
see this we're like Oh y-intercept is
negative 1
but there's absolute value signs around
this which mean the y-intercept is not
negative 1 it's going to be positive 1
because it has that negative that
flipping effect so I'm going to put if
that's 1/3 I'm going to go 1 2 3 so I'm
going to call that 1 you can see by the
way I've just that's like whoa that's so
high that's just y equals 1 but I'm
trying to use my graph according to the
particular values that I've gotten some
of you have run into trouble because
you've drawn with a set scale you're
like I always use 1 grid line as one and
then you're like oh my thing is tiny and
it's quite hard to draw so I'm gonna
draw my graph upwards like that and then
it rebounds it has that symmetry about
it ok now I always know with these
straight lines right if I get one
version here which is 1 minus 3 X the
other side will be exactly opposite
it'll have the gradient that is the same
thing but going in the opposite
direction so positive increasing rather
than decreasing okay so that's one and
that's 1/3 okay so we've done this first
one and then you start to think about
this sky as well now interestingly I've
got the same y-intercept here as I had
for this guy also goes through one and
what's gonna happen is it's going to
increase I put this in a very
unfortunate spot this equation I have to
rewrite it it's going to increase up
like this now I've got a quick question
for you right how did I know that my
orange line which is y equals x plus 1
how did I know that was going to collide
it was going to intersect rather than
like keep on going higher and higher how
do I know that they were going to
collide at that spot have a think think
about what you'd know about these two
lines
you know their intercepts you know that
gradient right restin what're you
thinking yeah very good the gradient
really is the key see how you've got
this three at the front right that means
it's it's really steep so you're this V
here and it sort of is quite narrow
right this guy here only has a gradient
of one in other words it's more shallow
I guess so you can see because it's more
shallow eventually it's got on a
collision course for this guy this guy's
climbing straight up and this guy's kind
of puttering along at a slower pace so
they're eventually going to collide okay
now because I know this intercept is
yeah right what I'm asking here is when
is this absolute value the V graph right
when is it
lesser there which means below when is
it below the orange graph and I'm going
to mark it just like I have for my other
questions I'm gonna mark in the spots
where that happens okay so you can see I
want to be between this x value which is
zero and this x value which I don't
currently know but you might have
already calculated who's got it
one is it one now when I look at my
graph right I'm like mm-hmm
this is a bit tricky I sort of eyeball
it I didn't use a ruler who else has one
I notice have one anyone else okay one
can we check this can we check this I'm
searching for one by the way this is a
nice spot let's have a look right let's
go y equals 3x minus one ah
now what's happening for you you're
right it has to be less this orange line
but now at this instant I'm thinking
that X values right so I'm not any more
thing about the bubble blue I've done
the above or below part that's the green
markings now I'm thinking about where is
this left and right okay so I'm gonna
yeah well let's let's is it all real
legs like is this part over here part so
I've got actually stopped at a certain
point right so let's just check the
algorithm algebra shall we three X minus
one that's this part of the V when is it
equal to X plus one
what what shall I do to both sides give
me a suggestion okay so I can subtract X
from both sides which gives me 2x I
suppose at the same time I can I can add
1 to both sides that's gonna be 2 so I
get this right actually I don't think
it's that bad on my scale I'm quite
proud of myself ok so there we go I'm
between 0 & 1 right so now I can say
this as an inequality from 0 to 1 the X
in the middle am I going to include the
batteries or not not there's my solution
okay now this last part I'm not gonna
get your graph I'm just going to show
you the graph and I'm gonna ask you to
tell me the solution right here's how
it's going to look to do this real quick
1 minus X is going to look like that you
can quickly tell me where the cusp is
it's not hard to find have a look
where's the cusp it's gonna be 2 so if
that's one that's going to be 2 and I
know it's got a great inner two so it
looks like this I know this is a super
quick and dirty graph but now let's
think about what the answer must be on
the basis of it okay how do I know this
line kind of looks like it's never gonna
meet with this loan they're sort of
going apart more and more and more what
is the key how do we know over here what
was the main thing was the gradient
right so this guy has a gradient of
negative 2 this one has a grain involved
mmm is it increasing or decreasing it's
it's negative 1 it's decreasing right
but this one is decreasing faster so
they're never going to meet in this
little spot okay so this question is hey
when is the absolute value that's this V
graph here when is it above when is it
greater than equal to this other graph
where is it it is always this guy's
always but you're never gonna catch up
over here this guy's not even trying to
catch up he's going in the opposite
direction right so this guy's always
gonna be beneath so answer for this is
which values of X all the values of X
are you gonna say just all of them dude
I'm done okay
now this this example is where we wanted
to conclude because it's a perfect
illustration of why the visual technique
is so powerful right
how much algebra did I have to touch to
solve this answer is you know
right the graph speaks for itself I
would actually have to put a few numbers
on here I was just noticing the bell was
rapidly gonna go but this is how useful
the visual method is okay if you wanted
to prove it algebraically here's how you
would do it you would go ahead you would
solve when does this thing when is this
thing collide with this thing but you
must notice you'll actually get a
solution for this so this is y equals y
minus X but watch what happens this
actually is probably worth noting before
you pack up can you all look up for a
second ever have a look who's wrasse and
ask a great question just hold on you
don't have to write this but do look up
and watch it write the question resident
asked was this actually is a perfect
thing to notice how do I do this
algebraically right if you were doing
algebraically you might try and solve
when does this branch equal this branch
but watch what happens something
important happens 4 minus 2x equals 1
minus X what shall I do to both sides if
I divide by X I'm going to turn like I'm
gonna get hi perverse stuff for that I
would like to avoid those can I do some
addition it's detraction what can I do
shame bother yep
if I add X to both sides I get that on
the left hand side what else can I do I
can subtract 4 I'm gonna keep on pushing
I don't like the language of like moving
numbers around they're not moving you're
doing the same thing to both sides I
subtract 4 I get this now what x equals
3 now you're like oh excuse me that's a
number no problem right there is a
problem a huge problem where is x equals
3 it's like over here right now you can
see why you got that answer you got that
answer because what you were solving was
this right but that's not part of a
graph because we did the absolute value
this is the danger of the algebraic
method it's kind of blind it just kind
of souls things and it gets answers and
it's like cool I like getting answers
that's awesome but you need to interpret
them and the graph is your main tool for
doing that does that make sense